SO MANY THINGS HAVE HAPPENED
SINCE WE WENT ON VACATION.
WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO TALK ABOUT
ALL OF THEM, BUT FROM THE
SERIOUS SITUATIONS, THE IRAN
NUCLEAR DEAL, BILL COSBY, YADA
YADA HAVEN'T FORGOTTEN ABOUT
YOU, BLACK LIVES STILL MATTER,
WHITE WOMEN NOT GETTING PICKED
UP-- OR GETTING PICKED UP IN THE
BRONX.
VERY BIZARRE.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
RIGHT?
BY TAXICABS.
AND TOM BRADY AND THE PATRIOTS
STILL CHEATERS.
BAM!
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
BUT OUR TOP STORY IS THE
KENTUCKY COUNTY CLERK WHO HAS A
LITTLE BIT OF AN ISSUE WITH
DOING HER JOB WHICH ENTAILS
GIVING OUT MARRIAGE LICENSES TO
THE GAYS.
>> WHY ARE YOU NOT ISSUING
MARRIAGE LICENSES TODAY?
>> UNDER WHOSE AUTHORITY ARE YOU
NOT ISSUING LICENSES?
>> UNDER GOD'S AUTHORITY.
>> Larry: PARDON ME.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO SAY
THE SPORTS AUTHORITY.
( LAUGHTER )
THE CAMPING DEPARTMENT WON'T LET
YOU GET MARRIED.
THEY JUST THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
RUIN ALL THEIR CAMPING
EQUIPMENT.
OKAY, SO SHE STOOD HER GROUND,
THE JUDGE PUT HER IN JAIL, AND
SHE SENT OUT HER LAWYER TO LET
US KNOW HER DEMANDS.
>> NUMBER ONE, SHE HAS NO
INTENTION TO RESIGN.
SHE WILL CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF ROWAN COUNTY AS SHE
HAS DONE FOR SO MANY YEARS.
AND NUMBER TWO, SHE WILL NEVER
VIOLATE HER CONSCIENCE AND NEVER
BETRAY HER GOD.
>> Larry: OKAY, THAT IS A
SERIOUS NUMBER TWO.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
YOU NEED TO SIT FOR A LONG TIME
TO COME UP WITH THE-- WELL,
WHATEVER WORKS FOR YOU, KIM
DAVIS.
ANYTHING ELSE WE CAN DO TO HELP
YOUR INTERPRETATION OF HOW OUR
SOCIETY FUNCTIONS?
GOOD LORD, SINCE WHEN DO FEDERAL
EMPLOYEES GET TO RENEGOTIATE THE
CONDITIONS OF THEIR EMPLOYMENT?
RIGHT?
I MEAN, LIKE HER JOB HAS TO
MATCH HER VIEW OF THE WORLD IN
ORDER FOR HER TO WORK.
YOU'RE NOT TAYLOR SWIFT.
YOU DON'T GET TO MAKE A VIDEO
SET IN AFRICA WITH NO AFRICANS
IN IT.
ALL RIGHT?
BUT SHE'S GOT A LOT OF SUPPORT
AND PEOPLE ARE CALLING HER BRAVE
BECAUSE SHE'S SPEAKING HER MIND.
( LAUGHTER )
SHE'S SPEAKING HER MIND.
BUT IF SPEAKING HER MIND
HURTS OTHER PEOPLE, THAT'S NOT
BRAVE.
THAT'S ( BLEEP ).
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
HERE'S WHAT I WANT TO KNOW.
WHY IS SPEAKING YOUR MIND A
QUALITY ADMIRED AND REWARDED
ABOVE ALL OTHERS RIGHT NOW?
DOESN'T IT SEEM LIKE THAT?
I MEAN IT, DOESN'T MATTER THAT
DONALD TRUMP CALLED MEXICANS
RAPISTS.
HE WAS SPEAKING HIS MIND.
I'M VOTING FOR HIM.
HE'S SPEAKING HIS MIND.
I CAN'T LET THOSE GAYS GET
MARRIED BECAUSE OF MY BELIEFS.
WE DON'T CARE ABOUT YOUR
BELIEFS.
THE WHOLE POINT OF HAVING A
GOVERNMENT JOB IS NOT TO GIVE A
DAMN.
THAT'S WHOLE POINT.
( APPLAUSE )
ANYWAY, TODAY SHE WAS LET OUT OF
JAIL.
NOW, HERE'S THE THING.
YOU WOULD THINK AFTER A SHAMEFUL
INCIDENT LIKE THIS SHE WOULD
KIND OF QUIETLY WALK OUT THE
BACK DOOR, GO HOME, AND
CONTEMPLATE WHAT JESUS ACTUALLY
CARED ABOUT-- MULTIPLYING FISH,
RAISING PEOPLE FROM THE DEAD,
TURNING WATER INTO WINE, AND
ALSO LOVING THY NEIGHBOR AS
THYSELF.
BUT REMEMBER, WE'RE IN KENTUCKY.
( APPLAUSE )
WE ARE IN KENTUCKY, AND IT'S AN
ELECTION YEAR.
SO INSTEAD OF COMING OUT
QUIETLY, SHE FULFILLED THE
SCRIPTURES BY EXITING JAIL
THUSLY.
>> I BELIEVE THAT HER ACT IS
GOING TO WAKE UP THE
POLITICIANS, THE PASTORS, AND
THE PEOPLE.
WOULD YOU PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME
TO THE STAGE, KIM DAVIS.
( "EYE OF THE TIGER" PLAYING ).
>> BOOO!
>> Larry: IS MIKE HUCKABEE
PLAYING "EYE OF THE TIGER"?
YOU'VE GOT TO ( BLEEP ) BE
KIDDING ME.
THAT'S RIGHT, THIS COUNTY CLERK
CAME OUT OF JAIL TO A CROWD FULL
OF SUPPORTERS WAVING CROSSES TO
THE THEME FROM "ROCKY."
AND NOT THE ORIGINAL "ROCKY,"
BUT "ROCKY 3".
( LAUGHTER )
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU GUYS, BUT
WHEN I SEE A GROUP OF PEOPLE IN
THE SOUTH WITH WHITE CROSSES,
CHEERING TO NOT ALLOW PEOPLE
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS, IT
KIND OF JUST GIVES ME A TINGLY,
LYNCH-Y FEELING.
( APPLAUSE )
THE GUY COVERED HIS FACE "OH,
NO! IT'S LARRY'S FIRST DAY BACK
AND
HE SAID 'LYNCH-Y'."
WHAT DID SHE HAVE TO SAY?
>> I JUST WANT TO GIVE GOD THE
GLORY.
HIS PEOPLE HAVE RALLIED AND YOU
ARE A STRONG PEOPLE!
>> Larry: OKAY, UM, I LOVE
YOUR PASSION, BUT BE CAREFUL
WITH THE NAZI ARM.
( APPLAUSE )
JUST SAYIN'.
BUT AS FAR AS FOX NEWS IS
CONCERNED, IT IS ALWAYS THE
SEASON TO MAKE A HORRIBLE
COMPARISON.
>> YOU KNOW, MARTIN LUTHER KING
JR. SAID WHENEVER MAN'S LAWS
CONFLICT WITH GOD'S MORAL LAW,
WE HAVE TO OBEY GOD'S MORAL LAW.
BUT THAT BELIEF LANDED DR. KING
IN A BIRMINGHAM JAIL, JUST AS IT
LANDED KIM DAVIS
IN A KENTUCKY
JAIL.
>> BOO!
>> Larry: ( BLEEP ) YOU KNOW
YOU'VE NEVER QUOTED DR. KING IN
YOUR LIFE.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
RIGHT?
COME ON.
YES, I KNOW IT'S A
GENERALIZATION, BUT YOU KNOW I'M
RIGHT.
SO LET ME SEE IF I'VE GOT THIS
A LADY FORCING HER RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS ON TO AN ENTIRE
COMMUNITY REFUSING TO DO HER JOB
REMINDS YOU OF KING'S 7000 WORD
MEDIDATION ON NON-VIOLENCE AND
RACISM IN THE CHURCH
I HAVEN'T SEEN SOMEONE MISS THE
POINT SO DRAMATICALLY SINCE THEY
MADE ROBERT De NIRO THE INTERN
IN "THE INTERN."
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
AND JUST TO CLARIFY FOR THE KIM
DAVIS SUPPORTERS WHO THINK THIS
LADY IS A DR. KING.
IN HIS LETTER FROM BIRMINGHAM
CITY JAIL, KING ACTUALLY
CONDEMNED THE CONTEMPORARY
CHURCHES AND SAID FAR FROM BEING
DISTURBED BY THE PRESENCE OF THE
CHURCH, THE POWER STRUCTURE OF
THE AVERAGE COMMUNITY IS
CONSOLED BY THE CHURCH'S SILENCE
AND OFTEN EVEN VOCAL SANCTION OF
THINGS AS THEY ARE."
MARTIN LUTHER KING WAS ACTUALLY
IN OPPOSITION OF THE CHURCH'S
UNWILLINGNESS TO SUPPORT THE
OPPRESSED.
KIM DAVIS IS USING HER POSITION
TO OPPRESS PEOPLE EVEN MORE.
( APPLAUSE )
GOING TO JAIL, GOING TO JAIL FOR
WHAT YOU BELIEVE IN DOES NOT
NECESSARILY PUT YOU ON PAR WITH
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
JEFFREY DAHMER WAS IN JAIL
BECAUSE HE BELIEVES IN EATING
PEOPLE.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE HIM A FREEDOM
FIGHTER.
( APPLAUSE )
AND, FRANKLY, IF YOU'RE GOING TO
COMPARE KIM DAVIS TO SOMEONE
FROM THE 1960s CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT, IT SHOULD BE THIS GUY.
THAT'S RIGHT.
ALABAMA GOVERNOR AND DIPPITY-DO
POSTER BOY GEORGE WALLACE.
WHO FAMOUSLY STOOD IN THE DOOR
WAY OF THE UNIVERSITY OF ALABAMA
IN DEFIANCE OF THE SUPREME COURT
ORDER TO DESEGREGATATE
>> I STAND HERE TODAY AS
GOVERNOR OF THIS SOVEREIGN STATE
AND REFUSE TO WITTINGLY SUBMIT
TO THE ILLEGAL USE OF POWER OF
THE CENTRAL GOVERNMENT.
>> Larry: THAT'S WHAT KIM
DAVIS SOUNDS LIKE, LESS LIKE
"LETTERS FROM A BIRMINGHAM
JAIL," AND MORE LIKE WORDS FROM
AN ALABAMA BIGOT. WE'LL BE RIGHT
BACK.